Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Oh,
song was everywhere in the 90s yeah,
everywhere.
Every mall.
It was always on.
The video was always on MTV.
It was such a uh,
such an orgy song and Nigga that is,
that's the name of the band.
Yeah.
If you were a swinger,
you participated in orgies.
I bet they played that song.
All it's,
every French person alive has come to that.
So the whole country orgasms at once and play it at your eighth grade
graduation.
Oh Wow.
You are an adult now.
Come with us like at your Bar Mitzvah.
[inaudible]
and it's one of the few songs to make it to make,
to get,
I can't talk to make it mainstream.
That incorporated like a pan flute.
Is that what that was?
But also it is without a doubt.
Ultra sexual.
Yeah.
And then if they don't have to,
not in the lyrics,
like he just listens to it.
Yeah.
Because the ladies coming as she's like heavy breathing and I know it sounds
like she's like,
give me two more threats.
That's what she's saying in French.
All right.
It's really,
really put a tail on me.
What are you checking there?
What's going on?
A drug,
Lord.
El Chapo has been extra day.
United States.
Oh,
snaps.
Ooh.
Did President Obama or elect Trump just text you that?
Dani t just texted me while he's pretty active on,
they said he uh,
he gives out his direct cell phone number to people.
I bet he does all the uh,
national security people are like,
you can't do yeah.
Like you can't have a president now phone.
It was set up by himself.
I think he became president just for the Twitter followers.
I think he does love Twitter.
I mean,
yeah,
a little too much.
Do you think he'll dial it back?
Maladies.
Surprise Pres.
That's really interesting.
Pardon me?
Really hopes he doesn't,
even though it's easy to critique him for it,
it's kind of fun.
Yeah.
That the president is like watching SNL and being like,
that's an else sucks cause they make fun of them.
Well,
I don't know.
It makes me laugh.
I think what's absurd though is that he constantly lies.
You remember the ticket thing you were telling me about this morning?
Like 30 people didn't want to go 30 Democrats.
Uh,
so I'm going to take it,
but it's not going to tell you God's.
Yeah.
Well that's part of why,
that's how he's a salesman in a showman.
And what he did was he built the Trump brand off of,
you know,
basically off of personality.
He's a reality star and he's really good at that.
Like that's really good.
A good lane.
So what he's doing is that's an extension of it.
So like all these,
uh,
I think it's something like 50 house.
Damn.
And that's not a good choice.
The choice you made was better.
50.
How's dams are not attending the inauguration.
Right.
So they ask him about it.
He goes,
I hope we get their tickets.
So many people want tickets.
So many people will tickets.
Yeah.
I would just,
I hope we get the tickets.
Yeah.
So it's just the positive spin thing on a bad,
which is actually a pretty decent approach to be taking.
I think that approach in life.
Yeah.
Is a good one.
It's a Barnum.
And Bailey,
it's PT Barnum.
Sorry.
No,
PT Barnum had the same thing.
He would create a spectacle to get people to pay attention 100% him.
It's a thing.
Look,
I hope it,
I hope it goes well.
I'm not kidding.
So do I do hope that these,
these next four years are good and uh,
yeah.
You know,
the,
I dunno,
there's not much more to say than that,
but um,
yeah.
Well what,
it is funny when he's like,
Aye,
everybody just wants to tickets.
Oh,
crazy.
Yeah.
Okay Buddy.
He's always saying he's doing better than he is.
Like approval ratings are bullshit everybody.
And you're like,
hmm.
Yeah,
yeah.
Who knows?
Who knows what's in store for more important things to talk about.
If you don't
look at this list today,
I know of notes that I have for today's show.
There's a lot to go over.
You ready to get this started?
Of course.
I've been waiting all day.
Let's go
your
children.
Okay.
And what's wrong with loving my eyebrows to scream at me?
Mommy,
me,
mommy.
Why Abuse Schema late?
Well,
no,
don't bring in one month into this.
Welcome.
Welcome to your mom's house tone circle rocks.
Christina,
you're going to spend,
um,
real quick before.
Mommy.
Yeah.
British mommy.
That was a British mummy.
Yeah.
As a British money.
Thank you Jane.
Scream at me.
Mommy
real quick before I forget,
I was just picking up.
I have a tour shirt that I picked up.
It's going to be on tour with me.
Um,
limited amounts obviously,
but it is online on our store.
If you go to Thomson [inaudible] Dot Com and you click on the store,
it takes you to our,
our merchandise page.
We have a bunch of stuff there.
Uh,
this one was designed by a really,
really great artists.
Dave Glock,
if you ever did meltdown every week,
a unique poster was created for the meltdown show.
Um,
like specific for that week.
It's a lot of work and Dave Glock designed each and every one of them.
Uh,
and he did the shirt.
He did the no teeth,
no entry tour shirt.
Like I said,
I'll have a,
I'll have a limited amount with me,
but they will also be for sale on the store.
That being that,
um,
really talk about that.
Uh,
sure.
I mean we'll,
we'll,
whatever.
Sure.
Well,
I'm just thought we should announce at the top of the show why not.
On the 12th of February we have a nine o'clock show added to your mom's house,
live in Irvine and having special guests,
Yoshi.
Oh,
by Shea,
the 7:00 PM is sold out.
We added the nine and we invited Yoshi to join us on that.
Uh,
if you want to do both shows,
we're doing two different shows and then when people are gonna want to know
super,
Super Mommy dy dynamics.
Um,
what did I want to tell you?
Uh,
I'm still recovering from 24 hours with burnt special fat loss trip together.
We did Joe Rogan a offered and uh,
came through with,
um,
you know,
I saw an opportunity,
I was looking for something fun to do.
And you know,
too often I think you go well,
just something in like nine months.
Wow.
And,
um,
that really,
really,
definitely pop someone's ears out,
just so you know.
Um,
I think,
yeah,
um,
you know,
I tried to look for something that was coming up quick anyways.
I see cavs are playing the warriors.
It's a rematch of the NBA finals last year.
So definitely the two biggest,
you know,
flagship names,
all teams in history,
basketball and then wait a minute,
it has throw stones easily.
Three of the best players in the game,
if not three of the best players in the last,
you know,
the history of it in the,
in the conversation,
James on the team,
he's on the calves that I must be unconsciously,
his name is sort of in the,
uh,
you know,
pop culture right now.
You come in tomorrow,
I got to tell him no,
he's going to be real.
So,
um,
but anyways,
he's on there.
Kyrie Irving's a cav big deal.
Steph curry,
Kevin Durant's,
she's on the team.
She's on the team.
Uh,
beautiful,
beautiful girl.
Difficult.
Yeah.
Clay Thompson,
Draymond green.
Anyways,
a bunch of stars,
great atmosphere.
And like I said,
a rematch of a game of the NBA finals last year.
So we go up there.
Well first we should start that burnt came over here and his drive or hit our
fence.
Um,
so I was like,
wait,
who's drinking?
Then uh,
bird comes into the house with like a 38 ounce Styrofoam Cup.
And I'm like,
oh,
I thought he had coffee in it.
Well let's,
let's see what time it was.
It was around 8:00 AM eight 40,
actually.
Yeah.
So the normal assumption is that it's coffee.
But then he walked by me and I caught a whiff and it was vodka.
Yeah.
And you're like eight o'clock in the morning,
he's going to go over morning.
It really hard to do every flight and then ready to which he went to the trouble
with me.
So then I got a peek inside.
Keep in mind,
let's hear about,
we all do lots and lots of flowing.
We all have our own rituals.
We all have our own way of doing it.
So I'm getting a peek inside how the party machine flies weekly cause this every
single week,
twice way their way back
in the house he's drinking,
right?
We,
uh,
first of all,
can we just talk about morning drinking?
Oh,
I don't think there's anything more disgusting and anything I could do less than
drink alcohol at eight in the morning.
I just physically couldn't do it appalling.
And I see it all the time cause I fly all the time and I'm always blown away by
it.
Um,
yeah.
Anyways,
we get to the airport.
He has special status on American Airlines.
Special special from what I was saying,
he use a concierge concierge key.
It's invitation only.
Concierge key.
They don't hit the level they invite you.
So he has so many miles from like probably doing the travel channel show to 100%
from being a travel guy and stand up at the same time.
So cheese,
especially that show because on the show he would do things like,
hey,
this week you're flying to Rome a come back next week Fiji.
Oh my God.
Because it was a television deal.
It was always first.
So you're spending so much money on that.
So just racked up the diamond diamond medallion.
Well,
they just saw like so much money being spent on your account though at this guys
for sure.
He has his own entrance.
Wait,
explain to me how at LAX,
so yeah,
you miss it.
Here's,
here's what you pull up.
The terminal four you'll see American at the end.
You see American priority,
which is like supposed to be priority.
I got,
yeah,
so it is for the elite flyers.
Just past that.
There's red carpet and somebody outside and a gray jacket.
Shut your mouth.
Gloves,
shut your mouth and that's where he pulls up.
Does every airline do this?
No,
I looked into it.
I figured you were American.
Has It?
United has United global services,
which is invitation only.
Delta right now has,
[inaudible] has obviously their diamond status.
They also have delta one,
which is if you're flying lax to JFK or lax to London direct or maybe one other
place that has its own entrance,
which is its own thing.
So it has its own land.
I feel like this is the special restaurant at Disneyland that you can drink
alcohol.
I only like five people in that fucking love this shit.
You're very elitist.
Yeah,
I would love.
And you love everything.
Elitist.
Everything that separates you from the masses,
the scum of the earth.
Oh my God.
You love it.
You do love feeling special at see,
look at the smile on your face right now.
Yeah.
Well I was just think about my personality.
Okay,
well the personality champ wouldn't see themselves as better than everyone else
and be fine.
I don't know.
You just got that whole on hoist up my slots.
So I do it.
But I,
I think part of like as far as air travel,
I talked about this with Bernd is that,
is that part of it is that we fly so much that anything that makes you feel
special and cuts down on the shitty part of travel is it's not so much that
like,
oh,
get out of my face
joke when I say that you enjoy elitism because
half,
yeah,
you like,
you like nice things,
but it does take the sting and this nice thing like I,
I like,
I like the one they happen,
but only because you make them happen.
And then I flog myself with eastern bloc guilt that like,
should I enjoy this?
Do I deserve this?
Like I can't just enjoy.
Nice.
Thanks.
So [inaudible]
um,
you go there,
there's a guy in the glove.
It's very,
he holds your hand first.
You walk in.
Um,
so there's,
uh,
there's a counter there and they just check you in.
Right.
You know,
they,
even though you can be,
we were pre checked in,
they check you in and print out a ticket,
give you the ID,
but they give it to the guy and then the guy,
the gray coat guy,
you're Copemon,
he takes us in an elevator.
I see grain elevator or the commoners elevator elevator shut up.
There's a secret elevator at LAX.
Well,
it's just that,
no,
it's from that,
that specific terminal to wait.
Here's the west part to the security level walks you in front of everybody.
It's the best.
They,
they sign off on it.
Then he walks you to the security counter and he puts your bags on,
God dammit.
And he offers to walk you to the gate.
Doesn't this blow your mind that that exists?
I didn't know it existed and that this,
they invited burnt.
Oh,
here's the other part about it.
So dammit.
So of course we go,
first thing we do is we go to the American club room,
right?
The,
uh,
you know,
like the diner's Club or those get allowance,
we walk in as we enter the bar area,
they go bird like cheers.
They know the bartender's like bird Tito's vodka.
So driven by the way,
what's the drink count?
Whatever you had before,
which I would say is to before he got,
because that thing isn't it?
Yeah.
Uh,
then he has to at that bar,
Oh,
so it sounds that were flying for San Francisco.
We're flying out of the remote terminal.
You have to get on the shuttle.
And that's for commoners.
So the shuttle,
right.
So Bartells the,
uh,
the lady was like,
Oh God.
And they're like,
okay.
And The lady comes over when we're at the bar and she's like,
I'm sorry,
this,
this and that,
but we,
you know,
I'm sorry.
And he goes,
no problem.
But as we're leaving,
another lady goes,
Mister crusher,
we were able to accommodate.
So and so's waiting.
So as we're leaving the lounge,
another lady goes,
uh Oh,
um,
you're,
you know Mr Chrysler can I,
he followed me.
Then she opens the door and we walked down the tarmac and we go into a Cadillac
and they drive.
Yeah,
they drive us to the remote terminal.
Then we,
oh wait another couple of drinks at that bar.
He was a separate bar there at the terminal at by the plane?
No,
it's a separate terminal.
So like we were at terminal four both flying out of terminal six.
Yeah.
And there's more drinks and more drinks there for you versus Burke.
Well I've had one at the first lounge,
but it's nine o'clock in the morning or something.
So you have [inaudible].
How did that,
did it feel really know?
The first one is like,
it's like,
it just feels like this isn't good,
but you know,
I was also,
I also approached it with like,
today's a fun day.
I'm going to do whatever I'm with Bert,
I'm just going to do whatever.
So he's like,
are you filming nursing?
Nothing.
Like he's like a college kid,
right?
Yeah.
So as we're leaving that I tipped the guy,
I the guy and uh,
I think most people don't tip or something.
He was like,
thanks man.
He goes,
Hey,
do you want a couple to go?
As I'm saying like I'm good birds like dope.
He fucking great.
So the guy makes us to to go on a coffee cup,
hands it to us and virtually fucking perfect.
Yeah.
We bored with our coffee cups with vodka sodas.
We Aye.
Aye.
I fucking nurse that.
When I think for the whole flight he finishes,
it has a couple more.
So now he's up to like six or something.
Anyways,
I would go to the hospital if I drink.
So we land,
we go to the hotel,
we have lunch,
vodka,
sodas for line with food obviously this time.
And then I go like,
wait,
I need it.
Like let's just take a chill pill till it's time to leave for the game.
We do that,
we go to the game.
The game ends up being a complete fucking blowout.
Like what does that mean?
Uh,
like I was,
I wanted to see a really competitive game because the two great teams,
right?
But w golden state,
Oakland basically destroyed Cleveland.
I saw this on social media.
Oh my God.
It was a total blur,
but it was still really fun.
We had amazing seats that Rogan hooked up.
So nice fourth row.
I'm just absolutely,
you know,
we got to see like these legendary players in PR,
like fucking right there playing.
Uh,
we had a lot of fun,
had a lot of laughs.
And then from there we went,
oh,
we go back to the hotel as we're getting back in the car.
He goes,
which is what?
My second wind and I go,
my wind is dead.
I need to lay down.
Because even at the game I didn't drink anything at the game.
He didn't neither did he actually,
no,
we smoked a little before Wednesday then.
But I thought for a minute you guys were sober for now.
No,
nothing.
But he's like,
I just hit my second one.
I don't even know how that's possible.
But,
so he goes to the bar and I go to the room and I lay in the room with the lights
off for like an hour,
maybe an hour and a half.
I go down,
then we go to dinner.
We go to the house of prime rib is a friend of his,
set it up,
a chef,
a legendary,
legendary spot.
Yeah.
It's really fun.
They're really fun.
Um,
we have this great meal.
We eat,
we go off the rails,
you know,
we're off the diets and everything and I honestly,
it didn't feel as good as I thought it was going to feel to go off the Diet
because it was too much food.
Yeah.
Like it was just enormous portions.
Uh,
I mean,
it should taste good,
don't get me wrong.
But afterwards you're like,
oh my God.
Yeah.
Because when you're used to feeling,
getting to the point of being disgustingly full anymore and now it's
destructive.
Hmm.
Don't get me wrong.
It was a familiar feeling.
I've done it many times,
but we were just completely stuffed.
Yeah.
Then we go back.
He rates his mini bar.
Um,
we smoked cigars,
Ellen the balcony,
and then this is the best part.
So the next morning we get,
uh,
they get picked up and go to the airport.
Immediately we go to the lounge and he's like a vodka soda to the guy.
He's like,
Tom,
I go,
I'm having coffee.
Because like,
I'm already like,
I need,
I can tell I need a full day to get over his craziness and like his normal way
of traveling.
Yeah.
Dude,
it's right back.
He's not,
he's right back into partying is what you're saying.
Yeah.
Not even partying,
just like,
let's get on a plane.
So,
so resilient.
Yeah.
By the time we land in La,
right before noon,
he's eight deep wow.
And totally normal.
We'll see.
That's the interesting part about barked Chrysler is that drinking doesn't him?
No.
It's so weird.
Cracking jokes.
He's the best.
He's just like having fun.
That's the part of this whole thing that you're like,
well,
is it so bad?
Two hours later,
I still don't feel good.
Well now you're sick.
Now you're coming down with a cold.
But,
uh,
it doesn't,
it just makes him,
he's already an awesome dude.
Like he's so sweet and fun and lovable,
and then he drinks and he gets more sweet and fun and lovable.
Becomes more fun.
Never Morose.
Never solen never angry.
No,
he's just like party Rad.
It's really,
really so weird.
Um,
I don't want it.
He plays up.
He always plays a,
what's it called?
He bought,
he always plays music in his videos that he posts.
So I can't really,
but like just this is us.
Go look at different,
he looks with no beard.
I know.
It looked like he looks like a younger man.
Actually.
That's us.
Yeah.
We're just,
Oh,
there is.
Okay.
Um,
so yeah,
this is Tommy.
You look great.
This is what's going down so crazy.
Look how good you look.
Jeans.
Oh good.
Look how skinny your face.
You look fantastic.
You look,
it's definitely better than a three months ago
of Avaya Soda.
Is that the girl you guys bang.
We'd doubled team.
That girl on the tarmac.
You guys put her in the Hammock.
We put her in the,
in the fucking the best.
Is that you and I went to the dentist and we did it the day you landed.
And what a Burt say to you about going to the dentist?
He,
Oh,
I go,
oh my God,
this is the best.
So we're in,
we're in,
uh,
in the morning on the way back.
I go,
I've got to go to the dentist today.
Who are you serious?
Oh my gosh,
look how many people are there.
I know it's crazy.
And I go,
yeah,
sometimes I think I know you.
And I go,
what are you talking about?
Cause you take care of your teeth.
Don't cause I'm going to a dog.
And I go,
okay,
why?
And he goes,
look,
a bird.
I took a picture of him.
Stones.
I took a
couple of skinny bears.
Yeah.
Holy hands.
She's those belong to,
uh,
I'll ask if you guys are going to share a room and then share a bed.
And he said,
you're going to do the s where one guy stays on top of the sheet,
stays on.
That was pretty funny.
So he goes,
I don't even know you.
And I go,
what are you talking happening here babe?
That's Bert I get is junk.
I know by the way.
Like no,
he took the pictures himself.
How he put it on the self timer thing.
I got to learn.
That's really funny.
So I know everybody does believe me.
Wow.
It's quite a weekend.
Quite a night guys.
So I go,
why do you not know me?
He's like,
when he's traveling,
I would never go to the,
I would never do anything like that.
It would never go to a doctor.
If I travel,
I don't do anything.
And then like 30 seconds later he's like,
well go to Bhutan,
Papa's podcast today.
Right.
And then later on these other guys are come over to podcast.
We'll go,
so you are doing things today?
Yeah,
but not a doctor's appointment.
And you go,
okay.
So then I was,
he goes,
when's the last time you went to the dentist?
You Go,
it's actually pretty bad.
It's probably like,
it's over a year for sure.
And he's like,
Oh,
you want to know?
Last time I went to done it like,
oh one,
I don't know,
three years.
At least 10 years.
Oh my God.
Really?
And he listens to the show.
I know.
She should know better,
man.
We got to get on Leanne.
Yeah.
Uh,
do we have the dental update theme song anymore?
Of course.
But you just,
you just screwed up.
You know why?
Because you brought it up without letting me fucking prep that song.
You know,
you get,
you do it all the time,
you know.
Sorry.
How do not know?
I told you,
I told you I had a topic rundown and I told you we were going to do dental
updates.
Yeah.
You don't care.
You're so grouchy today.
It's because you're not feeling well.
I know,
I know genes,
but you just,
we got to get through it.
You'll be okay.
I know,
I know.
I'm sending this right now.
Is it because Jack reacher was such a good movie last night?
I'm honestly blown away at what happened.
Okay.
We have to discuss the Jack reacher sequel after we do our dental updates.
Uh,
cause I tabbed out about 30 minutes in.
It's,
it was really special.
It is on fucking believe what happened.
Can I actually read an email while you're looking for the,
um,
dental update music?
No.
Oh,
how long is it going to take you?
Oh Gosh.
Sorry if you're crouched tonight.
So fuck fucking
God.
That's it.
Okay,
good.
I'm so excited.
So
that's all right.
Our
dental updates and he's like,
you know,
we haven't had a dental update in a long time.
Well,
we correctly flog ourselves because we kept reading them and we've been talking
about a lot how we haven't been in awhile.
We really haven't over a long time.
Well,
it's,
yeah,
you're,
yes.
A year for me.
Almost.
Yeah.
I think a little more for a little over a year.
Anyways,
we went again and we took her,
we went back to back.
Well,
we got a recommendation for a new dentist.
Yeah.
Because we moved,
you guys have to go and I gotta tell you I'm jumping ahead,
but there's nothing like that post cleaning.
It's so clean now still.
Yeah.
And you have to spend money on the preventative end so that you don't end up
spending $10,000 when it's right.
You know,
gum grafts and whatever the canals and crap.
Don't do that.
No dental insurance.
Yeah we have.
We pay out of pocket was $200 for both of us to get her or proofs or foods
cleaned.
You got to do it.
I mean dude my so go ahead.
Go ahead.
You went first to go ahead.
Well I went first because we went back to bag.
Yeah.
And he tells me,
cause this is the first time we'd been to the dentist,
so they do a full exam,
they check your gums for it and they check your mouth for mouth cancer.
They check your,
your gums for bleeding,
this health,
the health fullness of your gums.
And so the assistant takes down numbers and he says anything one,
two or three is considered normal and they go through every single gum area.
And all I heard,
all I heard was one,
one,
two,
one maybe like two,
three is around my crowns.
That's not my fault.
And he did the cleaning.
It was so quick for me,
you know,
I just laid down.
It was done.
And then I,
I asked him,
would you marry your mom and I,
and he and I will know.
And I asked him,
I go,
in all seriousness,
if you had to grade my teeth,
the condition of my mouth today,
what would you give me as a letter grade?
And he kind of chuckled and he said a,
did he really?
He did.
He gave me an a,
now I lied to you.
And I said a plus.
I was joking,
but he did give me an a and he goes,
you'd very little plaque.
He goes,
you've no stains.
And My stoma teeth look like they're in great condition.
I said,
thank you.
You know why?
Because I floss every day.
And he said,
I can tell.
He said that.
He said,
I can tell now,
here's the one thing that sucks.
I'm going to have to Redo one of the crowns that I have.
That doesn't sound like a no,
it's not my fault.
It's because the dentist that did it the first time,
he didn't line it up properly on the gum line and I'm having food caught in it
and that can be infected.
Even though that's been root canal,
I have to replace the crown so that it's flush with the uh,
other teeth.
Okay.
Not My fault.
Sounds like a made up story.
It's a story it sounds made.
I think people listening are like,
well that sounds like a made up story.
Why would I make that up?
Hey you have an a also,
you need a lot of work done and it's a lot.
I said,
one crown replaced that's through no fault of my own faulty,
faulty crown.
How would you grade this house?
And they go,
I would say it's an a now we're going to need a tear down that foundation.
You want to call a doctor right now and ask him what my letter grade was?
Let's call him right now.
He said a yeah.
And then you got in the chair and I said,
I'm going to apologize for my husband and advanced cause he's got filthy dog
teeth that need cleaning.
But it doesn't seem like a cool thing.
So what was your experience like in the chair,
Tom?
Going right away.
First of all,
I liked that they got down to business right away.
There was very little waiting.
Sometimes it's like doesn't lag.
Oh,
he's just with someone.
I hate that.
Hate that.
He got right on it.
He got too,
I forgot like first he does the drill where they just clean in between.
And then the second part is the hello.
I got a totally different treatment.
My teeth weren't covered in plaque.
Yeah,
well anyways,
my teeth were like a little sensitive and I was like,
Ooh,
that's felt.
And uh,
afterwards I got home,
I put my teeth were more sensitive.
He goes,
I really cranked it up for you.
And I go,
okay.
And I said,
yeah,
if you had to marry your mom,
no.
I said,
what?
What would,
uh,
what would you grade mine?
No,
you did not ask it.
Yeah.
He goes easily a plus,
Blah.
He goes,
hey,
said in a generation of noticing better teeth.
That's what he said.
I don't think he did because I was there.
And I could overhear what you guys were saying and I didn't hear that.
Yeah,
he did.
He said that.
No he didn't.
He said in all my time,
I've never seen a better set of teeth.
How much did your gums bleed during your cleaning done?
Are you sure?
I'm positive.
They do look so much wider right now.
Like mile.
Yeah,
they're really nice.
Can I tell you something stupid that I've been doing that you and I have been
doing together that I just,
it just occurred to me how dumb.
So every,
every day you and I have this routine where we go to bar stocks in the afternoon
and I get an iced Tall Americano with a splash of half and half.
Yeah.
Well I do it because I figure it's a cold drink and I can drink through a straw
and the straw will protect my veneers from getting stained with coffee.
I think like Rachel's,
Oh,
does that or something.
But what I didn't really put together for the last two months,
every time I drink that drink,
it hurts my stomach so bad.
Like it hurts and it's too strong a copy and it makes me angry and anxious and I
get like really,
really fucking crazy on it.
This reminds me of not having an outlet for the plugin to blood.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
It's like I,
I keep drinking it.
I know it hurts cause they've been amazing.
And then why don't I just order something else?
I would do that for years too.
For years.
What is that?
But why?
Why do we do this to ourselves?
It's just shows you how our brains work.
It's like
this is my drink,
this is what I order,
keeps hurting.
And then I keep doing it because it's,
the thing is when I order a hot drink,
it doesn't hurt my stomach.
Yeah.
It doesn't give me that.
So what I should be doing is ordering a hot drink and just drinking with a
straw.
Yeah.
Hello?
If it's,
especially if it's affecting your stomach hurts so much and I always just like
chalk it up to light.
Well that's coffee.
That's coffee for you.
I guess it just hurts.
Your stomach will love it.
What have you done that with,
besides the outlets?
Those totes.
Oh,
I got a little bar.
Remember for the longest time we only had like one iPhone charger in the house.
Yeah.
We're like,
wait,
we can buy to
my back.
Why wouldn't it?
You just have them around the house all the time.
Right there,
right.
Yeah,
of course.
Cause you just lose them by a few.
Um,
yeah,
I've done that with a lot of things.
Like I don't like the way that tastes good.
Again,
we don't one time.
The worst one I ever did was,
I don't think you remember this.
We went to a family dinner in Florida.
We were visiting,
we went to some Italian place,
which wasn't the norm for,
Oh yeah,
your dad hates Italian food.
I know.
Well I ordered a soup,
which I don't normally do.
Yeah.
And I took a bite and I'm not,
I'm not exaggerating when I say this.
It tasted like vomit.
It tasted like when you remember this restaurant,
I remember her.
I remember smelling it and it's like,
yeah.
And it's like when you taste vomit on the way up,
and you know what I did,
I had a second.
But yeah,
it's like I didn't trust my own reaction to it.
Right,
right.
And then as I was about to take a third bite doing,
I go,
I see what is this?
I don't know.
That's the blah blah blah suit.
And I go,
this is horrible.
Horrible me.
Like I was like,
I don't think you understand what type of horror I'm talking.
I really thought somebody vomited
and I remembered the suit because you had me smell it and you know my
sensitivity.
I go,
that's terrible.
That is the bomb vomit in a bowl and smelled like,
and it was served to us in a restaurant,
but I'm talking about like longterm,
like right now the toothpaste,
the aqua fresh that I ordered on Amazon,
it's not the right one,
but because I ordered like six tubes I keep,
I just insist on using it.
That fucking whatever you got.
And I hate the taste too.
And I keep using,
I'll just power through it.
Like I should just throw it away.
It's $10 where the toothpaste,
it's unreal.
The immigrant in me doesn't want to like
given,
you know,
of course,
and maybe it's the immigrant thing.
Oh God.
God,
nothing.
I'll never forget that fucking thing.
The vomit soup I remember and I remember that night.
Yeah.
Pretty bad.
Bye.
Wait,
you did not get an a on your teeth and I know you got a d minus.
Thank you.
Asked them,
will you ever date your mom?
You know what's funny about that clip?
The audience doesn't think it's funny.
I don't think that's true.
We never got much feedback on ass.
When you're married,
you think it just bothersome?
Yeah.
My feeling is because the feedback is pretty strong on all our bits.
Like zero feedback on this one,
but it's just like the gays.
But I do get that written in a lot of things I post.
Yeah.
Can I hear her again?
Uh,
I asked him,
asked him,
will you ever date your mom so weird.
Once in a while he calls me mom.
You know what I mean?
Yeah,
yeah.
I know.
Jimmying those rule kills.
Yeah.
Those are really,
he loves his company.
Somebody else?
No,
it wasn't the same gloves will let me get to this mommy lady today.
You want to see this?
Yeah.
So apparently what's happening here is that the lady recording isn't it parking
lot?
Um,
and she,
she is,
has a child in the back.
I guess the other lady who you see who you heard in the opening?
Yeah.
Calls her up and is like,
you know,
calling her attention and then accuses her of abusing the kid cause she's
tweezing her eyebrows while driving.
But I right,
I mean everything leads you to believe that the lady tweezing her eyebrows is
not doing anything wrong day.
Your mom,
this lady is just out of her fucking Milan probably.
Yeah.
It's usually how it goes on the show.
Oh,
hold on.
At my son's soccer games to cute dog and this crazy stuff.
So I was sitting here
at my son's soccer games.
Lady is yelling at me because I was walking.
My eyebrow mean,
do we know,
scream at me mommy
children plucking my eyebrows to scream at me,
mommy,
me,
mommy.
What?
Abuse Schema.
Yeah.
It's like she's just pulls it out of nowhere.
Stay out of her fucking mind.
I always think about when I see something like,
like for instance,
this club that that lady can drive.
Yeah.
And she has a cute dog.
But the driving part.
Yeah.
Well,
what about endangering your dog?
You dumb bitch.
I never drive with my dogs on my lap.
Who are you?
I am fucking
child to the advocacy.
Correct.
That's very made up.
Right.
And what's your deal with me?
Do not abuse you off too,
because I sat here waiting on my son's soccer game,
plucking my eyebrows because you hit him.
I hit my son and him and you hit and you screamed.
Really?
I hit my kids,
Jordan,
do I hate you?
Oh,
did I sit here and hate,
you know,
I was plucking my eyebrows lady
and she's like,
oh my God.
Geez.
So she's like totally gaslighting or too,
you know?
Yeah.
That's crazy that somebody would say that about
you realize that anybody says that to everybody else starts off believing them.
Well,
it's a pretty serious accusation.
That's what I'm saying.
Jesus.
It's like a,
if you make a rape accusation,
people don't,
you know,
the immediate thought is like,
oh,
that person's a rapist.
You know,
not like really I the even,
yeah,
you're right.
Just the stink of the accusations can take you down.
So this lady's like,
you beat your children.
I mean,
if people hear that and they go,
Hey,
are you hitting your kid?
That's crazy.
That's cool.
Crazy.
I don't care what y'all seconds.
Tom says,
I was born.
How?
Yo Baby Daddy knew why to town my babies hit the children.
I mean,
it's really a totally Luna Tech Person.
Yeah.
Pass them.
Will you ever date your mom?
My May.
No,
she looks,
I hit my kid
eyebrows.
Chill.
Drink
so fucking,
so it's like,
uh,
someone who's delusional.
Just could be a,
she could be drunk.
Oh,
right,
I see.
I don't know.
Mental illness.
Yeah.
It could be a many things going on,
but I liked it.
She calls her mummy.
I liked it.
So maybe she saw her plucking and eyebrow like shifting a children navy.
Maybe she had a few.
Yeah.
And she sees what she wants to hear.
It sounds like there could be some booze in that role.
Usually it's a little slurry.
Yeah.
Yo Yo chill
shit to say.
You know what,
this reminds me of.
Whoa.
I beginning to doubt your commitment to sparkle motion type,
right?
Yeah.
And Donnie Darko.
Yes.
She's the,
you know,
the big child advocate,
the absolute dance mom.
Oh my God.
Now that was an English accent and I wanted to,
um,
last week we did the roadman accent.
Yes.
And we,
I asked what is,
oh,
I see the little road.
Muna asked them,
will you ever date your mom?
Yeah.
So Rodman is the UK equivalent of homies from the hood in the u s the reason
they call them roadman is because in London slang to be in the area slash hoods
slash on the street,
they say,
are you on road?
It has only recently become a popular term in the last few years because of UK
hip hop and grime music.
Cockney has almost but disappeared from London and has been replaced by roadman
dialect.
Very interesting.
Another person explains Ben from England,
predominantly London phrase to describe usually a young male who dresses in
track suits and trainers.
Never high and tight jeans usually found patrolling as local neighborhood.
Being involved in illegal activity,
usually connected to drug dealing closely related to London.
Wrap grime culture.
Keep Glassy Ben Glass.
Yeah,
I like that.
It's money.
Well,
there you go.
There you go.
Um,
so much more here.
Uh,
you recall a few weeks ago we had,
remember the,
the guy who taught you how to do a threesome.
The Charlatan,
that fucking guy fucking thumb rings and the Pony Tail,
you know,
has it shit.
Twin goddesses.
How to hug clips.
I'm blind.
He put out how to hug.
First of all,
you know that you didn't see those two girls last time.
They're laying on their backs of,
there are a couple of dogs.
Probably.
They're way more attractive than I didn't think they were dogs.
I thought they were cute.
Really?
How could you tell?
Well,
I could just see he's couldn't see.
You couldn't see their face when God is activation.
No,
no faces.
I guess you were really paying attention.
You're awake,
cuter.
He can see her test,
test,
test.
This thing drives me nuts.
What?
When the fuck did this heart with your hand thing start and it's so fucking lame
and it makes me cringe whenever I see some dumb dumb do it.
Who is stupid commercial?
I hate it.
They make shitty jewelry and they go like one side open.
So that your heart then?
Yeah,
it's like a heart design irritates me.
Every kiss begins with Kay.
Is that the one where the celebrity designs the heart jewelry?
She's like
not k's but the yeah,
the open one side.
Yes.
11 to your heart.
But the heart with the hand thing.
I'm so over it.
But these girls are pretty,
no,
no.
Hold on.
The one on the left is,
and you can see her nips.
Nips or tips or fake huge Baker.
Yeah,
but I mean she's pretty,
but the one on the right,
do you think she's pretty
much prettier now?
The one in the middle.
He is such a fucking douchebag.
Fucking roof.
Fuck.
Is he wearing,
he's such a Douche.
She's got all these bracelets.
Any more sheer clothing.
And any more gold jewelry on,
it's the bangles on a man.
Oh,
bangle bracelets really make me want to vomit.
I mean,
I hope that there's a lot of drugs involved in all their choices.
[inaudible]
such
fucking throat.
Yeah.
And first of all,
anybody approaches you and hugs you like that.
I mean,
they're hands on your hips.
Are you Outta your mind?
It's the Trump hug.
That's how he hugs his girl.
Daughter of serious.
He Hugs Ivanka.
So they're waiting to do a third I kiss,
which is please don't
do this at least three times a minute.
Taking deep breaths together with them and they say,
this is how you should,
uh,
an intimate lover.
Not just this isn't for your lover.
I Dunno.
Oh,
I think you got a hug.
Yeah.
Feed those.
Teddy's,
by the way,
somebody just emailed us asking,
what do you call small sloppers cause they say that they enjoy our big slopper
terms.
So what would you call a tee?
A pair of high and tights like this.
Oh,
those are hungry.
Hungry test.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They're hungry because they need to be fed.
You gotta keep giving spoonfuls to those days.
Keep gaining some weight.
Yeah.
Can I tell you something?
If you were this,
uh,
passionate with me,
we went last of course.
Like it's so uncomfortable.
Well,
so the thing about this level of passion doesn't last with anyone.
It's all about that NRA new relationship.
Yeah.
You can't stay like this with someone for years.
It's absurd.
And I feel like maybe you could manufacture it like they do on that show.
Yeah.
The polyamorous.
Bad.
Because what he's actually excited about is that he ends up fucking somebody
else.
Course.
It was awesome.
It was like,
yeah,
fuck somebody else.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
This is
why you should,
this is how they would say hello.
Hello.
Got It.
This sounds a little annoying,
but do you see,
um,
how they're saying hello?
It's not like I can't just get a stranger like that.
God,
I can't take,
just want to see how much more inappropriate it gets.
That's the only thing I want to see because this is not us.
Hi Sharon.
So then the next call.
Oh,
so that was just,
that was the pre,
how's the prep buildup?
Hands on the hips.
Uh,
I love you.
I'm grateful for you.
Oh,
you to hold each other at a deep connected depot.
Coded
the other person writing the Phoenix rates here at
ease into that hub.
We're going to hold here.
So what's wrong with these people?
I remember
in high school that one kid,
I won't say his name,
every,
every high school had that kid that hug girls too long.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And it's the guy who's job it is to be the hugger.
Like the,
was yours named John too?
Yeah,
it was like this kid who was always,
he would always see him like that dude's always hugging a chick.
He was always giving shoulder rubs.
He's a guy that likes to cuddle.
I know.
Giving those shows.
No,
just cuddle.
Come.
Let's just cuddle.
Come over and of,
what do you think's going on with these types in life?
Yeah.
What,
but what is the deal with people,
this time of personality that has to do everything meaningfully that like is
that healthy or are they healthier than us is what I'm trying to say?
Because I'm uncomfortable with that intimacy.
I don't like that from a dude's perspective of a dude.
I think it's always a guy just trying to get laid.
I think for,
for a girl sometimes people are always looking for an identity.
You can be the identity of the meaningful spiritual.
I got a lot of love to give.
I have a lot of love to receive,
you know,
it becomes a lane I personality lane,
like that's who I am and that's my thing.
And then sometimes you see that person and maybe it does kind of affect your
day,
you know?
It's like it can be pot.
I think from a woman it can be positive like I've met.
It's very healing for a woman to be like,
yeah,
women like that,
guys like that.
I'm like,
all right,
well Sean bag.
Yeah.
See I go to,
I see this massage therapist lady who's really talented and really good at what
she does,
but sometimes her sincerity makes me really uncomfortable.
Sure.
And that level of like a part of it's because you're an elitist and what happens
is what happens.
What happens is you're,
you're actually in a,
an NRA.
No,
you're in a relationship.
Um,
a particular relationship that you,
it's unspoken,
but it's understood when you go there.
See,
and what happens is when someone gets real sincere,
they're kind of a massage.
Well,
you know,
they're kind of breaking the protocol of that dynamic right there to be
basically taken care of.
And there's an exchange,
you know,
there's an agreement.
You,
you're paying for services.
The person's supposed to not be like your technically your friend Sharman there.
They're taking care of you.
So they become really sincere.
It starts to break down the wall of,
oh,
are you the person taking care of,
I pay you money,
give me a nice background.
And they say things like,
oh,
you're having a wonderful day as well,
cause she,
I don't like it.
Like,
you know,
I'm going to touch your heart Chakra and you don't like that.
No.
Really?
I thought you would like that.
It makes me crazy.
Uncomparable shockers.
I like psychic things.
I like when she's like,
so I don't know if this means anything to you,
but I had this energy of Wilma Flinstone.
I swear to God.
She said that to me last time.
I don't know why does Wilma Flintstone mean anything to you?
And I go,
no.
Like I like that stuff,
but I don't like Shakara touches.
I don't like healing touches.
I just makes me like,
ah hmm.
But you've had that person before,
right?
Who gives the long meaningful hug?
The sole hug.
Oh yeah.
It's so uncomfortable.
Yeah,
it is.
It is.
I'm not into it.
I didn't know it either.
I do like a hug.
Yeah.
I like hugs.
I like greeting people and saying buy likes.
I just don't like the super intimate hug like a hippie.
Huck heavies.
Do I hate?
It's too much.
Too much.
Not Comfortable.
You can greet me with a hug though.
I like,
no,
I do too.
I'm a Hugger,
but I'm not like a soul hugger.
Like these people are like,
this is absurd.
Meaningful hugs.
Yeah.
100%.
This dude is not how I get it from the heart.
He's talking from his hips right now.
Yeah.
Bono.
This is just fucking stay.
Now I realize too,
this is more about even money because that's another workshop I teach.
You know?
[inaudible]
I'm leaking a little bit.
And then,
uh,
what about you
and a big tit hug like that from her and you're not noticing those big tits.
I mentioned her mushy purples up against,
here's my favorite move from my gut.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Swinging his hair
when he does this.
Oh,
that fake like,
yes,
yes.
I'm so earnest and sincere.
Yes.
Yeah.
The women are sincere.
The guy is just getting laid and the w as the Keller Oh,
special type of guy who's always looking for an opening and a girl.
Like for the girls that are like that,
like he's like,
I'm totally in the hugs.
Super vulnerable into,
yeah,
I'm like the sole.
And then that girl was like,
Oh really?
That's awesome.
You should come.
And do this and then he's making next week some finger in these two girls
and workshops.
That's a load of horse shit to
get high on your natural supply.
Come pay $600 to sit through my fucking workshop.
That's a big racket.
That workshops,
absolute fucking nonsense.
That's what that is.
Just go see a shrink.
Go pay a shrink,
a lot more effective.
Go straight to the source.
A vocal fry clip came.
Oh,
I love those.
Um,
let's see.
I haven't actually seen this one.
Let's see.
Let me see here.
Terrified.
I'm going down.
I'm not going to
as you.
That is not my voice.
My voice.
What do you mean this not your voice?
Because I know my own voice from when I was 20 this was submitted.
They said,
oh that's an over voiceover.
It's not.
This is no good,
good stop.
Look like
that's me.
I was sick that day by the way.
I'm just terrified.
I'm going down,
but I'm not going to fall down and die.
That is not okay.
So what happened there?
And the dogs
quiet.
Hey,
okay.
If that is me,
it's cause I was sick with a fever when I was doing that.
That's not my voice though.
Cool.
It
is not me.
You're the worst.
That's not me.
That's not my voice.
Sounds like you
recognize my own voice.
Okay.
When I was terrified,
I'm going down.
That girl has like an English.
I'm terrified.
Yes.
That's not me.
I can't be me.
I'm terrified.
Why do I sound English?
Just terrified.
I'm going down opening,
but I'm not going to fall down and die.
It's not me.
Fine.
I don't think it is.
You're not convinced it.
It's not even,
I don't remember.
It's 20 years ago now,
but it doesn't sound like Jean.
You know.
Everyone else keeps remembering to call me that and I love it.
Gee,
all the tabs are like changing need to do.
I forgot that guy called me that.
So funny last night we're in bed and we just want to like chill out,
watch something,
you know.
Kind of easy.
Not too involved.
Yeah.
Cause we were,
we got into dark mirror,
black mirror,
but then then you're fucking bummed out when you go to sleep.
It's negative.
I don't like that.
I got to tell you something.
He's really turned a corner with,
with the level of movie with this much Jack Jack reacher bruise is in Jack
reacher to,
and we saw Jack reacher one I think in theaters and it's your,
it's your like no,
not at all.
It's a good,
you know,
semi big budget we'll say because the budget's gets so crazy now but you know,
full budget production of a action movie and it has decent storyline,
good actors,
good action.
Like well done film where you're like,
you know,
that was a nice time at the movie and it's kind of neat that they named it Jack
reacher so that everybody can call it jack reach around.
Jack reach around,
which this one I should point out is called Jack.
Reach around to I'm,
I'm reaching back.
So in this one,
seeing the first one,
he gave front reach rounds and in this and read Jack reacher til he reaches back
and he,
he jacks off guys behind them,
which is like the big turn.
I got to tell you,
this movie is such a piece of shit.
I mean it's so bad on so many levels.
I know story is tear horrendous.
There's terrible writing,
terrible directing the actors.
You know what it was,
it seemed like,
cause it's a ton of production.
I know he had something a few years ago where,
uh,
you know,
him and seven,
the red stone and paramount got in this whole thing and he got this whole,
you know,
there's this whole,
uh,
you know,
back and forth of we're not going to produce Tom cruise movies anymore.
It was like all into Scientology.
Crazy.
Anyways,
so what you see during the opening clips that,
um,
that it's,
it says,
you know,
uh,
Tom Cruise production and when you're watching this movie,
you can't help but notice like are the,
it's almost like they said,
hey,
if we want to get these,
uh,
this list of actors,
it's going to add $1 million to the bottom line.
And then Tom cruise was like,
hey,
what if we,
um,
spent $30,000?
It's like so many bad actors movie.
That's what I noticed the first five minutes I turned you and I go there acting
like you can tell.
Yeah,
there's so much acting going on,
big acting faces and like,
yeah,
it was like,
what,
what did you say?
It's hard to put a finger on it,
but you know,
if you watch,
let's say one of those Seagal movies,
one of the gall like recent ones where it's a clearly a low budget,
low budget actors.
Yeah.
This movie is full of those like bad actors,
the writing,
there's like,
there's,
there's no,
nothing is plausible.
Nothing's believable.
No,
nothing makes sense when he confronts the guy no for like,
um,
oh sorry,
spoiler alert,
we're going to ruin the fucking piece of shit movie for you.
But for instance,
you know,
he confronts the,
his friends attorney that's been hired and he's like,
you know,
do you even give a shit,
whatever,
uh,
meet me there tomorrow.
And then they don't give you,
like the Guy Sees Tom Cruise is like,
why are you telling me this?
But then follows through with his orders.
It's not even in a four hour.
Right?
Like there's no like,
or what,
right.
There's no rapport.
There's no,
there's no black male.
There's not,
there's no stakes favorite.
The,
the,
the girl doesn't question really who he is and what he's doing.
An hour into this,
I'm just like,
wait,
who are you?
And she's been traveling with him.
All right.
None of it makes sense.
My favorite is he breaks into,
um,
military police prison.
No,
he gets arrested as a resident and then it breaks out of it.
And also there was one part that I,
this is where I tapped out is when,
um,
he goes,
you can't arrest me.
I'm a civilian now.
I'm not.
I used to be a major and he says about 500 times in the first 50 minutes.
I used to be a major in that.
And they go really well.
Did you read code 10.5 t of the seven h Henry?
And you're like,
that's it.
That's why you got him,
you got me a code.
And that's compelling for the audience.
Like what?
There's this one part where he,
so one of the captains let's say is bad,
they go to his house and they're like,
give us,
give us that file.
And the guy has it in his trashcan on his laptop.
So Tom Cruise puts him in a like an a grip and he's like,
give us the code.
And the guy's like,
ah,
ten seven two and then they type in 10,
seven two and it's correct.
And they're like,
thanks.
Leave.
Like there's no,
those scenes are supposed to be like,
you know,
a dramatic buildup.
And then guys supposed to resist and that's how you build the tension of like,
oh,
what's going to happen here?
Well,
and I think the biggest thing that they didn't address in this film is when does
he masturbate?
They don't talk about masturbating.
Another thing I should tell you one hour into the film where you're like,
I'm going to fucking blow my brains out at how bad this is.
Seriously.
An hour into the film.
This is such a bad,
and they haven't even shown him taking a ship.
No,
but I just that I hit the pause button to see how much time is left.
One hour.
It's a two hour piece of shit.
Like most action movies that suck,
90 minutes tops,
you know,
usually a little under that because they're like,
we're just giving you fluffier.
They make a two hour Turd Jack reacher reaching for turn because it's such a
shit fucking,
I mean,
I want to see if this trailer is as bad as the movie trailers can be.
Very misleading.
Yeah,
that's their job.
Yeah.
Well actually,
and he might,
but we should say marry your mom.
Oh,
John Wick two.
I can't wait to see that.
That's going to be trainspotting two's coming out.
I'm super excited.
To be fair.
He might drop off in the second hour of the movie.
Oh,
I'm saying I don't know what happened though yet.
Okay.
I have to break up how bad it is in the tea party.
Well,
we,
we own it because we bought it on.
So maybe tonight we can do part two.
You're going to have to kick catch me up to speed because I tapped out.
I don't think I should do that.
I think you should watch it.
I think you should see his,
the goons at the hired.
They're wearing sunglasses.
Yeah.
The bad guys with a really bad,
and I see
this is the best of the best.
I love this
one guy.
Took them all down with his bare hands
still in there,
Mr.
Well,
she has slowly
aggravated assault.
Is it felony in this state and Mr Mirror system and get him to Cairo.
Yeah.
Two things are gonna happen in the next 90 seconds.
Use me.
Excuse me.
First that phone over there.
It's gonna ring
second.
You're going to be wearing these cuffs on your waist prison,
mommy?
No,
that is one magnificent prophecy,
Mr. Reach here.
Whoa.
See,
it's not a bad trail.
Yeah,
keep on mind.
Good so far.
You're like,
all right.
The acting's acting thanks for tubing is on,
not Tom Cruise.
Tom Cruise,
one guy coming to DC.
I move around a lot
by the way.
So that exchange right there was thanked for tipping us off.
When he come into DC,
it's like that's their first time speaking right?
And she's,
and you're like,
okay.
He tipped off well,
but he's not in the army.
He just,
he knew about a crooked.
Well and why can't they just go to the sheriff's Office and arrest him?
Why did they have to set up that whole cafeteria?
I don't know.
It was so weird.
Yeah,
they set that up.
Thanks for coming to DC.
Um,
48 hours later,
he's like,
there,
she's been arrested and he's like,
I gotta get her out.
He's never even
never met her before.
I know now I will say Tom Cruise,
who has looked Amaz for the last 50 years,
I think his face is finally sliding off.
Turning a corner.
Yeah.
And I thought he got braces and he embraces yeah.
A while ago.
Yeah.
But they look crooked again.
They do.
I look and he's in incredible shape.
I think the guy looks like a,
what is it,
brick shithouse.
Oh,
right.
We're describing,
but yeah,
no,
he's in amazing shape.
Yeah.
But the face is starting to slide down.
It's riding off.
He's gotta be 50 something.
He's,
there's a scene is too old to be an action guy.
You know what I mean?
He refuses to accept that.
I know.
He's too old for this shit.
Let me tell you.
Does he doesn't do mission impossible anymore?
Does he do those movie?
No.
Yeah,
they just did one in the wild with him.
Yeah.
He's old as fuck now.
I don't know that he's old as fuck.
He looks like he's 54.
Um,
in the film,
there's one scene where they're fugitives and the guy's like male,
Caucasian,
male,
forties sucker.
That's definitely,
and he's like,
just put that in the,
okay.
It could be,
or television.
Cause we have a high def TV and I do notice you look away.
Worser on that high def boy.
Yeah.
Very unforgiving.
High definition television.
Uh,
oil boy.
I watched that new Bridget Jones's baby.
She looked fucking rough too.
Yeah,
yeah.
At the really,
she had like a lot of work done that right.
She did.
And then she denied it I think.
And that that's,
you know,
I don't know why people deny.
So check this out in the work.
Just say you did it.
Who Cares?
Mission impossible was 96 [inaudible] gray movie.
Excellent.
Love those movies came out in 2003 came out.
No,
six.
Wow.
Four came out in 2011.
Five came out in 2015 and six is coming out in 2018.
I love those movies.
I'll watch them.
There are a lot of fun,
but this pile of dog shit,
let's get back to it.
And he made it.
Folks wonder why you left Purple Heart,
Silver Star purple in the dusk.
People say you made it with someone's past.
Jack reacher for major Turner.
Major Turner has been arrested on what?
Charge?
Espionage.
He's been set up.
How much does it reach or no,
as it goes
bad guys,
the bad glasses on Pete follows.
You think you're invulnerable.
That's right.
So far though,
the is way better than the film.
And I remember we watched this trailer and we were debating on which dumb thing
to watch it or night and you go,
oh well that's definitely dumb.
So let's put that on the back burner for later.
Like this isn't a great trailer.
The trailer is good.
Here's the other thing,
the pacing.
Action needs pacing.
Yeah.
The scenes have no pacing time.
Maybe Steven Seagal ghostwrote maybe edited the film.
Directed and edited this film.
Rip your arm off,
beat you to death with it.
He's here to kill you
by men were shot.
It's bigger than I imagined ever.
Lose anyone on your watch.
Richard [inaudible].
I'm waiting for those rear race around scenes.
This movie he reaches between his legs.
You know,
I'm going to kill you off.
I'm done.
It's a tap down or I am bored.
Well,
we get to watch part two tonight,
but that John Wick Two's going to be a good one.
Yeah,
that'll be good.
All right.
I can't.
First one was really good.
Oh yeah.
I love,
you know I love Keanu.
I can watch him do anything.
I can do anything.
Um,
what did you marry your mom?
Well,
Marian mom,
can I,
oh,
somebody else submitted that.
They got a voicemails like their own silo may calls.
Yeah.
They said they'd be getting voicemails at work
and there we go.
Yeah.
Now
I want your ass home.
I want your ass now you got me now I'm going to raise some kind of hell.
You never seen you.
You
fucking ass right now
around you.
Don't get on that phone.
Call me back.
And we'd go on to have a hay day down here.
I'll show you how that shit goes
up on me after dinner and thank God I don't know.
Skip that and gone and that land is gone and all this bullshit.
You're fucking her right here in the building.
I think he's after weapon.
You get your fucking ass now.
God Damn little mother fucker
cleaner.
Yeah.
The best part of this is much like Salamay.
Hmm.
Um,
this lady is convinced that she left a certain person this voicemail.
Yeah.
So when she sees him,
she's like,
what's up?
You got to talking to what are you talking about?
You got,
you heard that message.
Don't think he didn't fucking hear that message.
And he's like,
I didn't hear any message.
I Avaya Toyota Vega tell you that cleaner.
Yeah.
And no
teaching your cleaner
psyche deed cleaners.
Yeah.
Well that accent,
no more solid may calls it right.
No,
but I've got a neat update.
Um,
I've been getting texts about idas.
Yeah.
[inaudible] ice apparently on Facebook activated his phone number and now I'm
getting text updates whenever I just gets a Facebook update.
So like Molly posted a picture of the people that had your number.
Yeah.
Is and then Salami and then woman to the nurse,
the nurse.
And she's been getting a lot of offers out of Boca Raton,
but she's not getting them.
No.
I need to update their information now.
So fucking annoying.
Usually her cause it's for a job.
Yeah.
You'd think shanaze would be on top,
but
so as far as um,
you know,
we were looking for boring things,
boring clips.
Uh,
we find out that the uh,
those engineer clips or fake that they were like an inside joke of mine
engineers.
But here's an actual and was kind enough to send us a truly boring,
but that's not a joke.
Oh,
thank you.
Yeah.
Okay.
The next section we'll be going to his section five.
That's the air brakes.
This guy looks boring following along term to your section five page five days
one and this section covers air brake system parts,
dual airbrake systems,
inspecting air brakes and using airbrush travel sometime called the uh,
foot valve or travel valve is what activates your brakes on the,
on your tractor and trailer.
And the harder you push on it,
the more pressure it will be a post on the brakes,
right?
Yeah.
The foundation brakes,
the beach axle right on your tractor and trailer.
Let's walk over and take a look at it yet.
Mock up.
I've had a foundation.
The airline will come into your air chamber.
This unit at this point,
when you press on the brake chamber,
right,
which pushes this push to boards or your board and
you may have an application pressure gauge.
Oh my God.
If you do,
that's a gauge that tells you how much pressure you're putting on.
You know,
this guy is so boring.
Check your brake system.
Uh,
you should,
uh,
do it.
Just like you were doing your pre trip and a [inaudible] apartment.
Please,
please.
That was really good.
I was bad.
Terrible.
Can I read an email update I got on eating Brown?
Of course.
You know,
we brought up the hammock clip,
which was a,
what's that guy's name?
Mcafee.
The famous guy that invented antivirus,
whatever.
Fuck he has women in Guatemala.
Is it or believes it was in the least believes in hammocks with holes cut out
the bottom and they should into his mouth to which I responded with,
well,
doesn't that make him sick to eat brown?
And so we got a couple of emails from some health professionals.
I thought you'd want to hear.
Ready?
Hey jeans.
After hearing a few of your podcasts about these disturbing behaviors.
I had to look it up.
I've actually seen people exhibit these behaviors,
but that's because I'm a nurse and a prison for Max security,
psych inmates,
inmates.
The truly funniest thing I've seen with fecal matter was an inmate who made
sculptures out of his shit as well as poo crayons.
He then wrote messages on the wall with said crayons at least once a month.
An inmate is eating their own shit pool to answer whether you'd get physically
ill.
I have never seen any of them get sick from it.
The pool pool you go and hold on.
We got another one.
Tom.
Christina.
I'm a support worker and one of my clients eats his own brown and his medically
well.
He eats it every day.
Once a support worker,
what does that mean?
I don't support worker.
I don't know.
Support.
Maybe that's from another country.
Maybe.
Why don't I just Google it?
Okay.
I'll support worker.
It might be a social worker and one of my clients eats his poop every day.
Every day.
Oh God.
Support workers can work in a residential care home,
don't domiciliary care or out in the community.
Their work is defined by a care plan,
which is often develop our social worker.
Okay.
God,
I was turning into the fucking eating my guy there for a minute,
reading and shit.
Oh God dammit.
Let us cleanse our Palette.
You
Buddy.
What you doing?
Yeah.
Yes,
Dan.
Nice.
Getting the next generation and on it,
you know,
in that glass.
Yeah.
Excellent work.
Really good stuff.
Um,
let me,
uh,
yeah.
Okay.
Do you know what that means?
Um,
I mentioned earlier,
my tour is beginning.
Where am I this week?
I'm in Milwaukee,
Madison,
many apple tits.
Uh,
I believe there's like a hundred tickets left from Milwaukee at the time of this
recording.
Madison is sold.
All three mini apple tits took shows are sold out and then a few days later,
next when the Wednesday after I'll be at Yukon.
I don't know if it's open to the public.
It might only be for students,
but I'll be there.
Storrs,
Connecticut,
exciting stuff.
The tour rages on.
So please go to Thomson [inaudible] dot com slash tour a lot of places coming
up,
Long Island and strong island,
Montclair,
Atlantic city.
Um,
I go to Chicago,
we added a show there.
Boston,
Bethlehem,
Pennsylvania,
mashed,
get a San Jose,
Burlington,
Vermont,
on and on and on.
Seattle,
Portland.
It's all happening.
Please go to Thomson [inaudible] dot com slash tour and of course,
February 12th we doing the podcast.
Your mom's house live in Irvine.
7:00 PM sold out.
We added a 9:00 PM show.
We'll do a new show with the great Yoshi Obayashi at nine Irvine Improv Jean.
Um,
February 17th and 18th.
I'm an la him headlining the Hollywood improv.
February 17th,
February 18th,
flappers comedy club.
April 13th through 15th,
Braya Improv.
May 4th and fifth fart.
Next Arizona,
May 19th and 20th do Dork titties at the Gotham comedy club.
June 16th and 17th,
man friend disco at the punchline comedy club and with jeans on February 12th.
Uh,
that's right.
The seven and 9:00 PM show.
Oh,
it's going to be exciting,
isn't it?
It's very exciting.
Of course.
Oh,
also,
we're proud to announce that we have added Amazon UK to your mom's house,
podcast.com if you want to use that when you shop in Amazon in Canada,
UK,
and the United States,
click on our banners for your support.
Go thousand ranch.com and buy some tickets to see those big mushy purples.
It's the best promo I've ever had ever,
ever of all times.
Yeah.
Eight done jeans.
I have some,
uh,
sorry.
Would you marry your dad?
What's that,
babe?
I want to read this email before I forget.
Oh yeah,
go ahead.
I think it's fantastic.
Yeah.
The subject says no other man like Tom and then in parentheses,
not true.
Thank you.
Her name is Talon,
I think are Taylan forgive me.
Talent in addition to my husband peeing on me in the shower,
hot boxing me at every opportunity and nicknaming my slightly soft stomach,
Chubby Tbi.
He has all,
he also thinks it's funny to try putting his toe in my,
but he does this one.
I am fresh out of the shower and standing on one leg trying to put my other foot
in my underwear.
His favorite times are when he can knock me off balance long enough to then
shove said toe in my face and ask me if it's clean.
I feel your pain mommy.
Okay.
Just keep glassing guy's a legend.
Uh,
okay.
That guy's awesome.
Yeah.
My deaf.
My husband definitely treats me like a 10 year old boy.
And all I can say is men like these only make our personality standout strong
because they exchange.
Very true.
Uh,
email says Tommy is mommy.
Tina kidding?
Did she hit her head?
I have a Bulgarian daughter in law.
Not sure what they do to those poor eastern bloc kids.
She is sweet but best personality.
You can include best personality champ to water and weight loss champ.
Thanks jeans.
I you seriously,
uh,
and then nerf dude wrote,
making a list of your husband's verbal trespasses is not the action of a
personality clean.
Interesting.
How you're only reading those in favor of you.
That's finally reading what's in front of me.
It's on the sheet.
Uh,
serious FARC question.
Have you ever farted on a scale and lost weight?
I have not wondered if it's possible.
Um,
I have not.
I wonder if it's possible.
I had my first double pike classic on Xmas Eve.
What?
Congratulations.
So excited.
I couldn't find words.
Thanks for all the important discussions.
Let's go water champ.
James.
I'm angry with me because an email I wrote in asking if you sneeze and Burp at
the same time.
Is that considered [inaudible] cars?
No,
sneezing.
A burp.
Was this this email?
Oh,
if I used to sneeze in Fart.
No,
but a lot of people have asked that too.
Is that something special?
It's such nonsense that they want to be rewarded or credited for something that,
I mean a sneeze,
you know,
it's a natural occurrence happens quite often.
And the fact that you know,
pressure is being pushed out,
it's quite common that you would sneeze and Fart at the same time.
The fact that we're going to act like that's something to be celebrated.
It's,
it's,
it's absurd.
It's like,
so what differentiates that from the double pipe class?
It's so rare.
It's like it's,
it doesn't make sense.
Usually that air chooses one canal,
it splits in two.
I mean,
that really is a magical,
it's like a triple rainbow.
It's like seeing orcas come up and feed at the sunset.
It's,
it's,
uh,
it's one of like nature's,
you know,
it's like a Mousse going down.
Exactly.
You know,
and,
and people go their entire lives without them.
That's true.
Sneezing and farting.
I mean,
several times a week you probably do that.
I feel like that is a rare occurrence to,
I don't sneeze a whole lot,
but I don't have that here.
Oh,
can I?
May I make a case for sneezing and farting place because when you sneeze,
you clench your sphincter.
Okay.
Yeah.
You're clenching.
So for a Fart to come out and make sound at the same time as this needs,
maybe that is a harder feet because the clenching naturally wants to happen and
it's not that special.
It's not this special.
I've never heard you fart and sneeze.
Oh,
I've done it dozens and dozens of times.
Yeah,
it's not special.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
so bro,
I know you are a big football fan.
We got some Eli Manning,
Peyton manning and I,
many Peyton manning post game interview right here.
These guys actually,
how long does this missed opportunities go through your mind?
You just think about the cop.
Well,
oh,
we'll see.
Obviously there's still,
if they're still right there,
this would hurts.
Um,
you know,
just when you,
when you look back and you,
and,
uh,
you know,
you'd see that we,
had some,
uh,
some chances and we had a good plan and you know,
had good place called at the,
at the right time to take advantage of what they were doing and,
and,
um,
you know,
just couldn't,
couldn't a lot of emails through the block,
righteous close.
What's the offense to really having to type out that it was capable of cabins
here?
I thought,
you know,
uh,
yeah.
You know,
guy,
I thought we were close.
Thought teams were giving us a whole lot.
Uh,
I used to get the ball down the field and find yourself on an Adl scale.
it was tough.
It was tough one,
you know,
help you,
you know what?
Yeah,
it's good.
But you know,
you've always made that distinction,
that a,
you know,
and you know what I'm saying?
It's not the same that that I'm a stickler the way you are about a sneezing and
farting.
It's not special.
Two one I've talked about how you sitting there in the first words out of your
mouth is,
you know what I'm saying?
No,
I mean,
no to hell we don't use it.
I don't know what you're saying and I don't know what you mean.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well you know as an a different category than,
you know what I'm saying?
You're talking about feel me.
It's different.
It's all different.
Yeah.
I totally get you.
Um,
are you ready for a oh,
this is fantastic.
This came in,
this kid records himself talking to his dad about eating ass and his dad is so
not on board course.
That is like,
that's a part of society.
Got The shitty mark.
No fuck on you.
And you followed any damn love.
Hey Man,
you Susan.
You Damn right.
So hold.
I never,
never,
we this crescent don't own shit.
So do you know any girlfriend about Oh,
in front of bad?
Hell No.
You know April's in front of bed.
No Sir.
Did you do your nose?
Don't be all up in our ass.
Hell No.
You never lit as like little pussy and at the same time know the asshole right
now.
I don't give a damn no daddy.
Stop line 17 that I ate.
I eat as before.
I don't give a damn if it's 30 17 motherfucker already siding eight no ass.
And I'm not going to eat no h
smart room really into not doing it.
Smart Guy.
Come on,
get that fecal to oral bacteria has a square eight.
Hey everybody.
Hey me about ain't no nasty mother fucking shot.
It's understandable how you see.
So Zoe never,
never,
don't go near that motherfucker.
You know what comes out motherfucker truth.
Who you know is that gonna look not that shit.
Yeah,
I agree.
Yes.
All right.
I ain't get no ass hole.
You got me fucked up.
2017 you've had a dog.
No,
she didn't.
We had no girls.
I just don't have no guide thinking the rest of your mind for the that's all
right then I'd be single for the rest of my life.
I got to eat as they have a woman.
Yeah,
you're like a 66 year old man.
You realized that you guys have the same outlook on it.
I agree.
Cause this guy knows how to live long.
He knows what he's talking about.
I don't take risks risk averse.
I don't have any stories about drinking all day.
Like you,
I don't have to worry about eating ass.
Like,
you know,
like I got beat with a pipe.
I think it's from drinking three days ago.
Yeah.
I won't get my Guy Day.
I call my Mama right now.
Oh Yo Mama Nigga see was a Cole Freak back and getting my ass.
Man.
Yo Mama ain't going to tell you no damn lie.
Like that
guy's hilarious.
Um,
you ready for some more high mommies?
Yes.
Thanks.
Jeans but waiting an hour for this.
This is what I live for these days.
How can I help you?
Hey,
what's your pronoun?
Hey Mommy,
can I get a,
a large black cold brew,
uh,
with no ice,
a large cold brew black,
but no way.
Yeah.
Actually.
Do you have poly by?
I'm sorry?
It's a,
it's a non-binary creamer.
No,
I'm sorry.
I do have almond milk.
Okay.
No,
just go black jeans.
Okay.
That's a mommy
three 44.
Thank you.
Thanks.
That's fantastic.
Wow.
That was,
the game has just elevated so much.
I,
how are you doing today?
I love these
thing and stuff like that.
Which is one oh four minutes.
Yes sir.
Huh.
It's a little things in life,
you know,
it makes life so much it nice jeans.
It's cheap you to keep the glass in,
man.
Yeah.
Cause it's so much fun.
It's so much fun as Corey.
Thanks Corey
jobs.
I don't regions,
uh,
how can I not had the ice cream cone as well?
Each Hampton all is why I'm here.
Melbourne pipes person,
but I prefer Lala lesbian cornerstone.
Thanks Mommy.
Amazing Egypt.
Holy Cow.
Ali and Egypt.
Wow.
Not Know we've had a Gypson gene.
That is so cool.
Very,
very well done.
Wow.
Very impressive.
Hello?
Look at them with the,
I'm sorry about that.
I didn't get paid today.
Hey Mommy.
A,
I've been slipping along this big huge menu.
Just glass and I think I'm just going to do a hot and spicy meat chicken and a
large drink.
They're going know our shrink.
Correct.
Okay.
To drink a double five classic.
It's like when you fluid bond,
two different drinks,
like half coke,
half Dr Pepper.
I don't know if you guys are probably by friendly
staff and half
coke.
Dr Pepper.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's correct.
Genes.
No thanks.
I've got family in Denver.
Drink.
Yes.
Alright.
They're to know.
All right.
Thank you.
Hitler.
Oh really?
Denver.
Hilarious.
I didn't get paid today.
Chris.
Jay.
Really good work.
Holy Moly.
Wow.
I like the idea of fluid bonding.
The two different drinks as genius.
That was other level,
and you get a real clear thanks.
Hitler.
Yeah.
Sneaking those.
Hitler's in his old,
it's bold.
Yeah.
A whole other story.
Ashley.
Oh,
let me pause please.
I'm only going to get a double cheeseburger.
Tibet please.
Yeah,
please.
Yeah.
Gotta get an Flt
toffee Latte.
No anxious,
glossy.
Thanks James.
An FYI.
Auntie.
Can I hear now and again?
I really like that one.
God.
Fal t and he goes,
it's double latte.
All right,
let me,
I'm only going to get a double cheeseburger for Berkeley's for Bert.
Yeah.
Bert,
you're right.
Yeah.
Got An lt
toffee latte.
No,
no.
Just glossing.
Ah,
masterful.
Masterful.
How was it
birds eating on your night out with him?
Uh,
well we ain't like tags at that house,
but did he eat more than you?
Uh,
probably.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Ah,
okay.
I got to say that from the time.
Hi Mommy.
Thanks gene.
Started to wear hi mommy thinks jeans know is now.
It's just like a quantum leap.
It's just,
you guys are so absurd.
It's so smart and funny.
Really funny,
man.
I never in my wildest dreams thought the game would elevate to,
to this.
Did you more?
No,
I mean,
who knew?
This is a phenomenon taking the world over very p here.
Well,
I love this guy and I got for you today.
Yeah.
Hey there.
Morning Mommy.
Oh yes.
Glass in here for a second.
Jesus.
Okay.
Question for you.
Do you guys have the same menu as like down in Hollywood,
downtown La in that area
are probably are some differences they have you looking at,
they had a couple different breakfast.
One called the Brown town.
Yeah.
No.
If it's like if you have a recipe for it,
we might be able to make it big mushy purple either.
I don't see no,
probably.
It's probably different.
They have like some health food stuff down there to keep you regular and all
that for the old folks.
You know what I'm saying?
For real snow.
All right,
mommy,
I'm going to have
extra hot MOCHA.
Pretty.
Please make those jeans high and tight.
I think that'll do it for me this morning,
Mommy.
All right.
Six 35 right on.
Thanks Gina.
Uh,
ah,
look at this smile and that's the look of contentment.
I'm telling you.
Until you've done it yourself,
you don't know the joy or he's also the barbecue master.
This is the barbecue.
Yeah know I retweeted this video because I thought it was just so great.
Oh Shit.
That's him.
Well now it's all connected.
All right.
Well thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you for the Q.
A.
That was delightful.
Really good stuff,
Molly.
Yeah,
sorry about that.
Okay.
I had you
well,
give my entire life and I would probably be a venti whole milk ice caramel
Macchiato.
Nice caring.
Uh,
yeah.
What would be amaze is such an large check.
Can I get a grande iced water also?
Anything else?
Uh,
no.
That should do it for my fluid bonding night.
All right,
thanks mom.
Really fluid bonding.
My fluid,
the fluid bond people added fluid bonding and nonbinary real quick.
He goes,
it's on the water champ.
I'll have the
yeah,
it's really great.
Fluid.
Bonding's a whole other thing.
I love it.
You believe in,
remember,
do you remember?
Um,
me,
I'm exhausted from now.
It's so funny.
Hi,
rock on the Wendy's.
How may I help you?
Hi Mommy.
Just glass in real quick glance at the menu.
Glass in class.
Okay.
Number one.
Small,
medium or large?
Medium please.
And your brain coke.
Alright.
And then can I get a double pipe?
Classic.
A double?
Yeah.
Double.
Please.
Can I have that medium?
Cause I'm at birth.
And your drink coke.
Okay.
That'll be it.
Alright,
thanks jeans.
Unreal.
Nothing makes me happier because I'm not hurt.
Yeah.
Caddies make.
Thank you for tizzy panic spreads names.
Oh,
would you like Tracy and from Ernie firecracker chicken.
I know that to me.
Mommy,
can I get up handable with Chow Maine and like kiss my pussy chicken.
Okay.
If tenable.
Chow Mein and Harry Yankee tickets.
Yeah,
that's great.
Okay.
Can I also get a site owner of the,
uh,
how you say a Eggrolls Yag roles?
Yeah.
You also get a side order of the,
how you say a Agros
the egg rolls,
the chicken
and then a sign of sweet and sour as well.
That's it.
Thank you very much.
It's going to be out the window.
Now what this gentleman added is,
okay,
you see what he did?
What?
Masterful.
Thank you.
Bernie firecracker chicken.
He didn't leave his name.
The masterful thing that this gentleman did is the kiss me kiss my pussy
chicken.
And he did not he,
he gave her the space to answer back the Teriyaki chicken.
That's the key.
If you can throw out the most ridiculous thing I notice are doing that though.
You have the silence.
You own it.
Yeah.
And then you let them let them go.
Oh,
did you mean the double,
right?
Yeah.
Right.
That's the best is the Ma the letting them drink.
Translate what you just said.
God Kiss my pussy chicken.
I,
oh my God.
That's really crazy.
How'd you say aggro?
I was hilarious.
I wouldn't have done that in a hundred drive throughs,
but I didn't even know panda express had dry through to do.
Actually no,
I didn't.
No clue.
I wonder if that's nice.
Cap me,
California.
We don't have those here.
Ah,
fucking fuck.
That was great.
Kiss my pussy chicken.
Kiss my pussy.
Just
all right,
we got to go James.
All right.
I'm exhausted.
I know jeans.
I know.
Uh,
thank you guys for genes and up with us.
There's a lot of fun.
We'll see you in a week,
by the way.
I don't know if you guys noticed how much water my husband drank and how much
I've been drinking.
Go ahead and show the audience how much you drank this whole episode.
Go ahead.
I'm tired,
but not a lot.
He drank too much or too little Yorkie.
Sips.
Yours are Maltese sips,
minor Doberman Gulps.
I finished those two.
It's water soda counts against your water intake.
Everybody knows that.
Soda.
Oh,
what is it that it's water.
I was NAM water.
How can the,
what does it say?
Zero Calorie Soda.
It says here it's water.
It's just soda water,
but it's got sweetener in it so it takes away,
no,
it doesn't have to suite near water and tea and it contains,
so it's negative water.
It contains caffeine,
so it's negative three.
Well,
this one contains caffeine.
Let me see yours.
Caffeine free.
Okay.
I don't believe you.
You just says free.
It says somos cashier.
No Art.
And Joe says Tom's teeth were d minus your worst dog teeth.
Let's go water champ.
That's me.
Thank you guys for listening.
We love you.
Paul.
Please tell the audience so I can have record that you're impressed with my
water consumption.
You're the water champ champ,
or as long as I've known you in the water.
How the water,
even the water camp for as long as I've known,
you know,
let's go.
Let's go.
Let's go a chat on the water out in the water.
The chat on the water.
Power the water.
Talking about water champion.
Tom,
let's go.
Let's go.
Let's go for Watertown.
I don't the water out of the water or the water channel out in the water.
The water.
Water down,
drinking that much water drinks and
oddly enough,
my wife also competed.
She paid laugh.
You ever seen the big water?
This my overwhelm marriage to consume more water.
Water,
water,
water.
Water.
Water Chair.
Kept drinking and no one said a word.
Water.
Let's go.
Let's go on a chat on the warrant.
Out on the water.
Let's go.
Water Champ.
Now on the water.
On the water.
Definitely water too.
Let's go.
Let's go for a lot of champ.
Go to those four 16 ounces of water.
The water champ.
Let's go.
Water Champ.
How in the water?
Power the water.
Let's go.
Let's go water champ.
How in the water?
The water.
Let's go barter champ.
Let's go butter champ.
Yeah.